hello everyone and welcome to another
really enjoyable game from round two of
the video world cup 2021
uh it's a game between mikhail krasenkov
and kiril alexeyenko so alexenko you
know
we've seen many games by him as he
qualified for the 2021 candidates
tournament well
really 2020 candidates tournament but it
also continued in 2021 due to the
covet situation uh and his opponent and
this is a game two of their match in the
first game uh that ended in the draw uh
krasnkov
obviously had the black pieces but this
one is a really enjoyable one a lot of
you have suggested it and for very good
reasons as
krasenkov is known as uh well as his
wikipedia page says
his playing style is aggressive and he
has won many best game awards
and he's uh okay this is a photo uh when
he was a bit
younger he's 57 at the moment and
alexenko is 24 so almost twice his age
uh so you'll see how how uh vigorously
he he led
the attack in this game so without
further ado uh let's check it out
and um uh well see see how the game went
so uh kresenko with the the white pieces
opens with knight to f3 he goes for the
righty opening
uh we have d5 d4 knight to f6
c4 and e6 so we're just transposing to
the normal queen's gambit declined
we have g3 now uh going for the e40
catalan and now
bishop to b4 with check with bishop to
d2
and now that uh black made white develop
this light square bishop
poorly like this he just goes back
bishop to e7 we have bishop to g2
and now both players just castle we have
castles castles and
knight b to d7 so both players just
continuing development this is nothing
new
uh it's been played many many times so
queen to c2 white also continues
development
c6 now strengthening the center and rook
the c1 there are many possible moves
here
uh rook to c1 one of the more popular
ones
we have a5 trying to grab more space
here on the queen side and now
a4 by white we rook the e8 and here
there are a couple of games that reach
this position usually people go with
some like bishop the
f4 or knight to c3 but here krasenko
went
knight to a3 and it is now as a movie 11
then we have a completely new game
so let's see how kiril uh continues here
uh here after knight to a3 we have
bishop to d6 he shifts the bishop to
this uh well that's sort of a better
square as he controls
this diagonal and now bishop to f4 and
you don't really gain anything by
doubling white spawns here if you
capture capture then you already have
these nice pawns the knight is coming to
e5
and it's going to be a very nice setup
for white so here black of course goes
e5 and
why why wouldn't he if white allows it
you of course will play it
and now we have a capture fest here in
the center of the board it's been a
while since we've had one
uh d captures on e5 knight captures we
have bishop characters bishop captures
c captures knight captures and now
knight captures an e5 we rook captures
on e5
and now only after uh the c4 square has
been freed as the pawn is no longer on
d5
knight to c4 so the knight is actually
rerouted to uh to a very active square
we have rook back to e8 it also
came to c4 with tempo so rook back to e8
and
now rook to d1 putting pressure on the
knight and also just
having some ideas of maybe e4 attacking
the pin piece
so bishop to e6 black even allows this
because now after we play e4 which was
played in the game
uh black had uh knight to b4 in mind now
saying okay we can trade queens you
capture here i'm going to capture on c2
so queen to c3 white just moves the
queen to a
well to a more active square and keeping
the black queen attacked here so queen
to c7
now black rooks are also connected and
now knight to d6
there's a there's a this one moment to
do this because if you allow rook 8 to
d8 then you will no longer have this
move and now of course white will cement
his knight and d6 would move like e5
uh rook to a7 the rook on e8 is under
attack and now
e5 defending the knight here queen to b6
and now white starts uh well just
doubling
rooks on the default you have to get the
the last piece into the game so rook to
d2
and now knight to d5 centralizing the
knight again
as checking if white is willing to give
up his strong bishop but of course white
is not interested in that
we have queen to c2 and now rook to d7
and black will now also double rooks on
the d
file so rook a to d1 rook 8 to d8 and
now comes
rook to d4 white slowly grabs more space
here
uh he keeps an eye on his a4 pawn now
with the pawn and
with the rook and with the queen and
also you can shift the rook into the
attack if if needed and if black allows
it of course
so knight back to b4 now attacking the
queen and
queen to c1 now we have h6 by black
and now comes rook to h4 and this is
sort of where the fun really starts here
black has to decide how to continue this
game as long as this knight
is on uh d6 the black doesn't really
have any
uh sort of way to activating his rooks
because that's the only open file on the
board
and you don't really have all that much
to do with your other pieces so
you could try to to do something like c5
but
black decides to attack uh ferociously
with
f6 now he challenges the e5 pawn and of
course if you capture then your knight
here will fall but
there is one move that black allowed by
playing f6 so feel free to pause the
video here
and try to find this uh well very very
interesting move while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh well
always trying to sacrifice something and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's rook captures an
h6 of course this is how we start the
attack and i know a lot of you guys
thought well of course it's rook to h6
but the question is
how do you continue the attack it's not
all that easy to bring your other
pieces to help you out with the attack
there's no good way to you know bring
the knight into the attack
you can't really do any rook lift here
the g3 pawn is in our way here the queen
guards this square so
we can't really you know bring the rook
into the game this way
so it's a it's a very interesting
sacrifice and uh well
black now has the capture because if you
don't capture it uh
it just means that you haven't
considered it and i mean
no one admits that so here g captures an
h6
queen captures an h6 and now well
although you would really enjoy
capturing an e5 if you do this then
queen captures on e6 of course
everything falls apart for black
so here we have queen to c7 now saying
okay now i can bring my rook to help out
with the defense if needed
and here queen captures on on f6 now
attacking the bishop here
and bishop to b3 here black is still
trying of course to play for advantage
uh maybe maybe you know uh just a nice
rook captures and e6 would
make life a little bit easier for black
characters characters and the game
continues from here
but black wants to uh you know keep
everything he plays bishop back to b3
and now white plays bishop to h3 now
attacks the rook here and says what
what are you going to do and now you
don't really have this if you if you try
to do this now then your queen is
attacked your rook is attacked bishop is
coming to e60 and there's no way black
can survive this so after bishop to h3
we have rook to f8 now attacking the
white queen
but now bishop to e6 with check
we have bishop captures and e6 queen
captures with check
king the h8 uh and now queen to h6 with
check so of course uh you can't block
with the rook
uh because then queen captures an f8
happens and you're getting checkmated so
you have to go back
kink the g8 and now rook to d4 now the
rook lift is possible
but still black has so many defenders
how can how can white win this
uh well here black decided that okay
i have many defenders but i would enjoy
having even more so he played
knight to d5 trying to bring another
defender into the game
but this is a pretty big mistake you
should you should play some like rook to
g7 rook to h7 get your rook in front of
the king so you don't have to worry
about moves like rook to g4
or even rook to a7 to prevent moves like
queen to e6
check but he played knight to d5 and now
he allows
white a very very strong attacking idea
queen to e6 with
check we have king to h8 and now comes
the move that
probably alexeyenko missed when he
played knight to d5 as you know
that's often how chess works so feel
free to pause the video for the second
time and try to find this
incredible idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
uh spotting this uh well it's not very
often that we go
forward with the night but it is of
course knight to e8
and congratulations to everyone who
found this now the problem is the queen
is under attack but
there's an even greater idea here and
the the problem is you can't just
capture the knight of course black would
be willing to give back some material
but now you have to go to the 7th rank
and if you go to the seventh rank that
means the rook and queen will no longer
be able to help out with the defense
along the seventh rank
so here we're just going to deliver
checking g7 rook g4 check and now
whatever you're gonna do let's say queen
to h5
checkmate and that's it so instead after
knight to e8 we have queen
to d8 okay now black says okay how are
you continuing the attack
but now queen to h6 with check again you
don't have rook to h7 because the rook
here hangs
uh and that's the beauty of it because
now the knight also blocks the
queen's defense of the rook here so you
have to go king to g8 but now comes
rook to g4 check king to f7 and now
the the incredible knight to d6 check
and he was in this position on mu 41
that kill aleksanko resigned to the game
as and as the first game ended in a draw
this means that
mikhail krasenkov is on to the next
round and alexenko is out of the feeder
world cup
so here you resign because it doesn't
matter what you do you're in check
and if you just for example move the
king king to e7
it quickly ends rook to g7 check rook to
f7 and of course rook captures will be
checkmate
without the help of the queen even uh
okay the queen helps out
by uh you know checking out that e6
square but
you know it's also uh very nice as it is
but
uh after knight the d6 check if you
don't move it if you capture the knight
uh it doesn't help you because now rook
g7 check king the e8 and not the very
nice queen h5 check while the rook
covers the entire seventh rank
so the king has nowhere to go you have
to block with something
and now it always means that you have to
start giving up pieces and once you give
up everything
it of course ends in checkmate so really
an incredible game
uh with the white pieces by mikhail
krasenkov who uh
as uh as we've mentioned in the
beginning is known for his uh incredible
attacking style and he has
won many games like this and won many uh
great game awards but here
uh like i said he's almost uh twice
alexenko's agent to win
a game like this it really um i i think
he he
he was definitely very happy with
himself and i'm pretty sure you guys are
happy that he
played this great game uh as well i put
a smile on my face that that's for sure
and it's always enjoyable when someone
accomplishes something like this in in
such a
you know big tournament uh so
congratulations to mikhail krasenkov on
this beautiful achievement
uh and that's it i hope you guys enjoyed
it really was a wonderful
one if you have any other suggestions
please use use hashtag suggestions so i
can check them out
as there are so many games being played
i can't even uh you know
begin to follow all of them but that's
why you guys always help out with
with your suggestions so yeah once again
hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank david kimura uh
luang ha roger raj
nikki slana and john mullin for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day